in Köln auf der Bezirkssportanlage
Ehrenfeld sind rund 600 Fußballerinnen
und Fußballer aktiv kicken geht aber
wehe man muss mal seit sage und schreibe
vier Jahren sind hier die Sanitäranlagen
kaputt die Klosteranlage sind gespart
und bei den Duschen fließt kein Wasser
mehr katastrophale Zustände also wenn
Kinder hier während des Trainings oder
auch während Turnieren auf die Toilette
müssen dann muss entweder ins gebüch
oder du musst nach Hause das geht so
nicht wenn wir mal auswärts fahren D
sagen wir mal zu den Kit die sollen sich
nicht dran gewöhnen dass wir zu solchen
luxusverein fahren die eine umkleider
haben und Toiletten ja seit nun mehr vi
Jahren sind die Toiletten und Duschen
geschlossen der wagegrund es gibt
hygienische Probleme mit dem Trinkwasser
das bekommt die Stadt einfach nicht in
den Griff sechs mobile Klos sollen
helfen aber das ist keine zumutbare
Lösung doch damit nicht genug auf derl
Spielen drei Vereine Hellers Köln
Eintracht Köln und DSK Köln da kann es
schon mal eng werden meist ist nur der
Kunstrasenplatz bespielbar weil die
Hartplätze häufig so aussehen eine
einzige matschfläche und weil die Kicker
sich nicht duschen können müssen sie
klatschnass und verdreckt nach Hause
fahren also es ist unheimlich schwer man
kann sagen
desaströs was hier passiert und dass wir
hier alleine gelassen werden obwohl wir
das alles ehrenamtlich machen ist fatal
also gerade Köln als Sportstadt ist
meiner Meinung nach diese Anlage
mittlerweile ein Schandfleck das muss
man so ganz klar sagen das wird die
Anlage wird komplett ignoriert im Kölner
Rathaus versucht man erst gar nicht die
unzumutbaren Zustände schön zu reden
eine kurzfristige Lösung sei aber nicht
möglich schriftlich heißt es auf der
Bezirkssportanlage Ehrenfeld kann eine
grundlegende Sanierung einzelner
Bereiche darunter der Duschen momentan
nicht erfolgen das gesamte Gebäude muss
entweder vollumfänglich saniert oder neu
gebaut werden viele fürchten dass hier
gar nichts mehr passieren
wird ich fühle mich wie Donk rote ja der
also s gegen die möhlen der Stadt Köln
kämpft in Anführungsstrichen wenn solche
Sachen da sind wenn man dann anspricht
und fragt was ist damit jetzt ist mein
Sohn acht und keine Ahnung ob es wenn er
erwachsen ist ob es dann irgendwann mal
bessere Verhältnisse sind jetzt plant
die Stadt Köln Container aufzustellen
die sollen provisorisch als Umkleide
duschen und Klo dienen im besten Fall
passiert das in 8 Wochen es kann aber
natürlich auch länger dauern